I've seen four of the Eight Episodes I'm
very curious where this is gonna go what
is it like being part one of the things
I enjoy is when I do I can't predict
where things are going to go and one of
the things about this show is you really
don't know whose side who is on so how
much were you told when you signed on
your full Arc and how much were you
actually finding out script by Script I
think we had like a chunk of scripts
that we you know that we had to begin
with I forget exactly how many but then
after that they would they would travel
out as we went and we then did have to
wait for quite a long time to hear the
to read the final episode and to see the
resolution so
um I think we knew at least speaking for
myself everything that I needed to know
about the character to to approach you
know each episode without knowing all
the turns along the way what about you
guys yeah I mean I didn't know anything
uh you know
um and
you know it's it's what the character is
too you know so it's like to not know
what's going to happen and so
um it was more of a just who who you
work with you know is like it's for for
me
like look looking at at the show like I
wanted to work with people in the show
um
so I didn't I didn't I didn't demand to
know what's going to happen to Edward
yeah same here I mean I just thought it
was an interesting character and
we're just lucky to be able to play in
it you know and after that after that I
was just like I mean I I just assumed
like bad stuff would happen to my
character like you know yeah yeah like
yeah I just make them really
uncomfortable uh I am curious how have
you been describing the show to your
friends and family it's all about this
FBI agent who
uh centers on Joe Maddie
I I mean it's it's a thriller
um it's it's action-packed it's uh it's
smart and funny and they're great
characters I would say it's I describe
it as something that you got to pay
close attention pick up all the hints
and um it'll keep you on the edge of
your seat
I I always tell friends and family don't
don't watch it because of me uh you know
it's like a good show and it is you know
like just uh you know it's it's the when
I read the script
um the first time you ripped through it
and I want to know what happens next I I
saw the cut of the first four episodes I
wanted to keep on watching it and I I
know what happens you know but do I I
don't think it actually
explained the show to my friends
that was a question right yeah yeah it
was a it's just that they were all just
like oh cool you're going to Canada to
shoot something I don't think I've ever
told them about the show I I have some
actor friends that are in the same maybe
that's a whole other thing let me ask
you let me ask you a different thing
okay so one of the shows one of this
series is about private Espionage and
how much do you think of what's being
depicted in the series is actually
happening in the real world I think
honestly a lot I think
I think some of the big concepts are
definitely the same but they were put in
different words
right something like that yeah I think
I think uh I think it's yeah there's
plenty of like more than one would want
to know I think you know or do if you
want to know it's it's just kind of
disheartening I think
um especially someone like myself that
identify with the sheeple as they call
it yeah
um like I don't like being manipulated
yeah you know I like what they're
presenting
like on these apps like oh I really like
that sweatshirt you know so they're
doing it well right you know nice next
week
yeah it's just like yeah yeah I think
the main thing is that um uh we're all
being manipulated without realizing it
by you know what is being presented to
us it's it's uh it's scary but I think
it's true yeah it's always been
happening probably but I think we're
it's much more sophisticated now like
with the data collection and and you
know the and computers and in the
interconnectedness of the world it's
like it's so sophisticated what you know
the information that they can have about
you and and
um yeah it's very daunting to think
about and and it kind of makes you want
to go out into the woods and you know
put your phone in a lead box or
something but I think that if you use a
credit card you're effed that just tells
everyone everything I don't have a
credit card actually you're copying keep
their keep your character oh yeah oh
really that's right oh no that's because
I'm European right and we don't have
credit cards
he just has a hard roll of cash
out of money in the woods
um for soon to be fans of the series uh
what do you think they would be
surprised to learn about the actual
making of the show
um well I mean I'm still always blown
away when I see things that are supposed
to take place and like say New York oh
yeah and it's not yeah I did it was
really fun to see the the New York
substitution it's a pretty good one I
mean it's incredible it's like oh that
that subway stop doesn't go anywhere you
know yeah you know our subway stop on
the streets of Toronto but it's I I
actually wondered that when I saw that
and I'm like I know this isn't New York
but this does look very much like
they're in New York I'm like good
production design yeah I agree I think
that successfully looks like New York
for sure I definitely want to know uh
one of the things about nowadays there
is a lot of television and a lot of
options
um and I'm just curious for people that
will be watching this interview what do
you want to tell people like about why
they should watch this show over say
something else well it's
fun ride and an exciting show but it's
also a smart show so if you like to
watch something that where you have to
be engaged and pay attention and you can
pick up on the hints and you can you
know come up with theories but then know
your theories will be thrown out of the
window and you know come up with new
theories uh if if you're into that kind
of Engagement with a show then I think
this is a the show for you Kiefer uh is
someone who I have grown up watching I'm
a big fan
um he's also a super nice guy so can you
for all three of you can you just talk
about
um working with him and maybe what
surprised you about working with Keever
we said earlier that he's a rock star
yeah I mean I remember Rob
and literally rockstar I remember you
said to me one of the first days
shooting he came up to you or something
and you were like wow he's a rockstar
I I say so many things that he's like
he was I mean he's just incredibly
generous and just he really is there for
fellow actors
um you know a lot of times you're on set
you don't you don't really hear any
feedback or anything but he was just
like extremely generous about saying hey
you know going out his way saying that
you you know you rock or that was great
you know yeah and and just you know
things you don't have to do but as as uh
you know it when when it happens it's
it's like really appreciated so for sure
very generous and if you're gonna do
this kind of Thriller action show and
you get to do it with kefir I mean it's
like working with the master of this
type of this genre and so I think we all
felt really lucky to be on the set with
him that no no need to rap I'm just
gonna say I hope it's a huge hit for you
guys thank you and I'll talk to you more
tomorrow